let's go to Ron DeSantis as a product as
a product Charisma can you go face to
face against Trump no way you're not
going to win uh trust me ask Marco Rubio
on Ted Cruz you're not going to be able
to do that uh trolling can he go up
against Trump nope you're talking about
a street brawler from New York good luck
trying to do that side okay where can he
go and do that uh military background
everything he does that needs to be at a
military unit because he served in the
military and he was a Jag lawyer for
Navy SEAL unit all this stuff Trump
can't do that he can't kind of like
remember back in the days when Dukas has
tried to set himself up as a leader and
he's in the tank boom it was over that
is actually an audience that he can play
off of there's 30 million veterans in
America that's a big vote you can go
work off of that and we'll look at look
at this guy he looks like he's a
military guy he looks like the
commander-in-chief if he goes and talks
about his track record during covid is
there anybody above him on handling of
covet are you kidding me you got to work
she's there she's not running yeah you
got the well I agree totally you're
right you got the woke who couldn't
stand your policies you forced them
while they had BLM on the floor to host
the NBA finals in Florida I mean how
much of a I would be talking about that
24 7. AOC came to your state for
vacation during Christmas this should be
like you know the greatest hits that he
can go on Non-Stop now this is the other
part
that sometimes uh uh Megan if if if
let's just say I'm assuming you assuming
you and Tucker have spoken I'm not
asking for you to answer that I'm just
saying I'm assuming you and Tucker have
spoken why is that an assumption well
because Tucker is probably a good idea
for him to call you why is that a good
idea uh because you've been through this
before okay in a different way but you
know what that experience is to go
through with Fox so he's probably called
you I'm assuming Tucker's probably
spoken to Beck and maybe even spoken to
Bill O'Reilly why because these were all
at one point cream of the crop right
there is wisdom in calling somebody else
that's gone through what you've gone
through
do I think Governor Ron DeSantis has
called others to ask for wisdom of what
to do or do I think their Camp thinks
they know exactly what they're doing I
don't know but if I'm a betting man I'm
more betting on them thinking they know
what they're doing rather than leaning
on others who have been through this
before to say what should we do with our
marketing strategy should I be out there
more I'm in Israel yeah I'm doing this
you know hey he's looking tired what
should I be saying when I'm doing this I
think there's an element of that where
you got to bring some of the right uh
supporting casts around you to help with
the strategy uh who knows look in about
two weeks when he's going to be making
an announcement that he's running
because you know he's got a lock in his
Governor position maybe in two weeks
when he comes out Megan he's going to
shock the hell out of all of us he's
going to take the gloves I'm saying
ready let's go because I'm free now you
were thinking I was afraid I've not been
afraid I couldn't make the decision
until now let's roll and maybe we're
going to be shocked but until then I
think a lot of the criticism he's
getting is fair
um he's going to be in Iowa at the same
time as Donald Trump which seems like a
disaster waiting to happen I mean like
that seems like taking on Trump and his
territory remember Trump last time in
Iowa was literally giving people free
helicopter rides in his helicopter
he's the marketing guy he gets marketing
Trump is a marketer
for true I mean that's how he made most
of his money before the Celebrity
Apprentice was just marketing out his
name and getting paid license fees you
know he didn't actually run these
buildings he let them use the Trump name
which you know used to be not that
controversial it's different now all
those uh buildings along the Upper West
Side were used to ride the West Side
Highway was Trump from Trump not a
single one has that anymore because it's
the Upper West Side
um but it's tough to have it like Head
to Head where you're trying to charm
people and out charm Trump but I think
you're making good sense I mean like
maybe he could lean in if I were to
Sanders I don't know how to say this
because I complained that he didn't come
on the show and give me an interview
because I really think he should have
done that but I actually if I were if I
were to santis I would say go on with
somebody whether it's me or somebody
else who can help you own your foibles
your weaknesses who can help you make
fun of yourself like I would ask him
what's with weird the weird head Bob
what are you doing that like why am I
seeing these videos If you're looking
like that it's like kind of off-putting
I would ask him that I asked Putin why
is doing all these shirtless photos
trust me I would ask DeSantis this
question and then we have a chance you
have a track record of asking those
questions yeah I do and then and then
we'd have a chance to laugh about it I
think people would get to see him be
maybe self-deprecating maybe own like a
A little weirdness about him maybe he's
like a little nerdy you know I don't
know what the like
the answer is not to keep yourself in
only protected spaces even Trump you
know next week he's going to do a town
hall on CNN which is like okay that is
not a safe space for Trump I'm actually
kind of curious about the strategy I
don't think there's a lot of gettable
Voters on you know watching CNN right
now I see why CNN wants to do it
um but I applaud the decision to sort of
go in places where that are unexpected
you got to respect that right I mean you
know when you when you think about
boxing UFC MMA we like fights you gotta
love the guy that's willing to go
anywhere anytime to brawl and fight
there's something about that that's very
attractive and appealing with Trump
wanting to go on CNN strategically
logically on 70 different points we can
say don't do this it doesn't make any
sense but what's he gonna do is Trump
going to wait for Fox to flip their
positions from DeSantis to Trump because
you know a lot of times you're hearing
about the news that you know the fox is
taking a position with uh DeSantis over
Trump and even the poll that came out as
a fox poll that's showing Trump ahead of
DeSantis so Trump's not going to be the
one that's going to wait for Fox to want
to support him that's not his play he
will go find a media you know why
because there's certain people in the
world that when you put the camera in
front of them they get eyeballs people
want to know what they have to say
there's not too many of them he's at the
top of that list when he talks people
show up and CNN knows financially
they're making the right move to get him
on there but I know you're saying is
there going to be anybody to flip there
I think you and I may be surprised how
many people are sitting there and saying
really I have to choose between this guy
and and Joe Biden I mean I mean I I
so many people that are not politically
conservative or libertarian or
independent
Megan Joe Rogan just said if he had to
choose between Biden and Trump he's
going Trump
if you would have said Joseph people may
not know this he's a lefty he wanted
Bernie Sanders last time he wanted
Bernie Sanders so Elon Musk is now
sitting there saying anything but Biden
so you know I think um
the uh you don't need as big of an
audience as we think we need you need a
small percentage of people to flip and
if CNN's willing to host it you know
what he's going to do he's going to
troll them he's going to mock a lot of
people he's going to tell a couple jokes
he's going to call on and push his
agenda and they're going to ask him
tough questions he's going to flip it on
them the interviewer is going to be just
as scared as anybody else to interview
him because he knows the interview is
going to flip very very quickly when you
interview somebody like Trump and he's
going to handle it but you know again
the question is conversion you're asking
the right question we're going to find
out 16 months from now whatever the
timeline is 15 months from now 17 months
from now if it's going to work or not
foreign